foreign
[Music]
together inshallah you know and then
answer a few questions the questions
you're going to have to think about them
though guys yeah
number 10.
hamidun
mananta
man make sure you read with me guys you
got the uh
have you all
yeah I knew you've got the book is the
book with you in the community
Safa
is
still searching for the page
page 54.
yeah
I'm gonna write less than one
yeah so listen tonight on the board now
[Music]
who are you he's addressing a male
I am a student in the
University notice how he used a bar bar
is a harmful drug I forgot to write this
but
everyone say that
it's basically a preposition yeah like
fee
like Allah like
like min
foreign
[Music]
Biden for example okay
are you a new student
yes I am a new student yeah
but that translates as sometimes with
but here it takes the meaning of feet in
normally back I mean with
but let's
not go with the other meanings for now
just say it means
yeah I mean in this case fee yeah
as well yeah
uh I mean Aina Anta
Anta
where are you from
Hindi
and I'm in Hindi
I'm from India
smoker
what show
is Muhammad
it's me Muhammad
my name is Muhammad
um
and who's this young boy the one that is
with you ma'aka
means with Ka is you we call it
the calf addressing
you this comes in book two but I write
it anyway yeah what do you call it guys
careful
calf is like this calf
means being addressed
yeah we call it
huh
means to be addressed in some
circumstances can mean messages as well
this means a message yeah
the one or that is in that case yes well
done so Manhattan
who's this young boy the one that is
with you
yeah
well done
who was the melee whoa
who was Emily
he is my
classmate or colleague well done
Hindi
[Music]
is he also from
India Avon means
also
write that down A1 means also
la
bandi
no he's from
Japan
what's his name
yeah
foreign
[Music]
I remember we've touched on it so that
yeah I want to write it here for you
guys this year is called
hard foreign
[Music]
exactly and when his Lord called out
comes
like yeah Muhammad
Muhammad takes how many dumbers
but normally Muhammad is how many
numbers
which is the
yeah
enters upon a sentence Muhammad
the one being called upon takes one
number that's just the rulings in Arabic
yeah if you're speaking fusa Yeah
like
a lecture they read
very formal yeah
um
you don't really have to you know most
people don't but it has you know its
place within time and also context yeah
muhammadu
ation
too
my language is Urdu
yeah we have a strange one isn't it
because it is
it an easy language
Nam
here
foreign
what's his language
[Music]
and his language is Japanese it's a hard
language
a detached pronoun who remembers
damirable fossil huh
what's the mere Moon fossil who
remembers
it means that which is a detached
pronoun like whoa
and here huh
who is a detached pronoun here is a
detached pronoun home is also a detached
detached pronouns we're going to learn
this
it's funny because damir can also mean
conscience as well damir can also mean
like what's running through your mind
your conscience that's also another
meaning
you see
I was right in here so this can mean
conscience as well Danny Allah
what's on your frame of mind what
suffering mind you're you're in yeah
it's got a few meanings yeah it can mean
your heart as well
your heart
uh okay muhammadu
ated
where is your father o Muhammad
my father is in Kuwait he is a
nah singer and a doctor
he is a well-known famous doctor
effectively shaheer yeah write that down
shaheer
don't forget these words guys yes
shahiron
some people say
yeah
well known
okay
muhammadu
oh sorry I completely skipped I'm trying
to finish it too early
um
where's your mother
here Aidan Phil Kuwaiti
ah here is
foreign
she is also in Kuwait with my father
muhammadu
have you been to Kuwait yeah Muhammad
nah I'm the Hub too yes I went
Nam The Hub too
that's my nephew
I never went
foreign
this is the correct way according to the
book but we'll get into the other ways
in which it can be said a bit later
okay
foreign
where is his father
who are tired
father is in Japan
he is a big Merchant for a big
businessman
yeah
well done Muhammad
U
do you have a brother o Muhammad
um
yes I have one brother
is
foreign
language translates as lion
yeah the lion has many many names from
them is
who can guess
I mentioned one as well
I said
huh
lace
wara
foreign
fleeing from a lion yes in the Quran
also
yeah you know what she believes
some people say
libda is the main of the Lion
yeah
I like her do you have I like her
do you have a blood brother what do you
say
I have a blood brother
well who am I
who am I
feel Madina
foreign
and he is with me here
in the enlightened city of Medina
and I have one sister
[Music]
foreign
I have one sister her name is zainab
her name for a female is a
male
well here
and she is in Iraq with her
foreign
engineer your favorite job
we're here
makes that which comes off to it take
Kasra it's like a preposition okay so ma
thank you for reminding me and Shane
foreign
and it brings benefit to you
that companionship of some sort is at
play
and also it could also help with the
understanding of the coming together of
two things that sounds quite long-winded
so it shows that you're within the
company of a person or something or
somebody
yeah for example
you're with me
and with you are those individuals
yeah mahu
a
and with him there's a two man
yeah
companionship which is the coming
together of two things
I've got a good one
in Morocco what did they drink with
couscous
no no that's all star you drink lemon
yeah it's difficult they drink I know
maybe it's just up in the north but they
drink Lebanon of course you don't know
this one
yeah I'm trying to get out of here yeah
I know about Etsy that's sometimes
before and sometimes after
you for mashallah uh
so basic yeah curd mode literally
foreign
okay
all right yeah so my
you feed also brings benefit of the
coming together of two things
means two things
okay
okay next page
do not know what Huna means
means here
it's also
who knows
also ishara
ishara
yeah
so it's used for that which is close
all night is only used for that which is
or close yeah
this is just additional yeah
you know what erock means in Arabic
language it means it means a separation
between two things
yeah it's got a meaning
okay we're going to activate deep I've
written it down anyway
okay so lastly
foreign
do you have a car oh my brother
ton
Hamza II in The Who
yeah so we start again
foreign
that's the proper way you say la my
indeed
I don't have a phone yeah
okay
so we've got several questions how long
has it been uh as in
23 minutes should we do some questions
all right so do the first
five questions for Nabil
foreign
questions
I'm going to answer some and I'm gonna
ask the majority yeah so smoker
so what's your name you say my name is
where are you from
yeah so you would say Logan
[Music]
yeah
for example if you want to answer this
one what does that mean
ah what would you say
baby in my
house
with my mom at home
she's in the house well done
oh I know this one already
so Lee basically is the usage of that
which you always own this is what was
explained to me I've seen the opposite
but basically use Lee one uses Lee
which means belonging to me for things
that
cannot be taken away from you for
example your brother cannot be taken
away from you you'll always be your
brother even if he passes away
yeah
uh as for Indie I have you can say that
about a pen because a pen can be taken
away it can be the possession of others
after so Lee is always used for family
members
yeah
how many problems you got
you forgot you got a lot done
so you would say
yeah so you say
how many brothers you got just say free
for now
is that correct how do you say three
brothers
I love to
foreign
so that means the first
word what does it have to be
uh we're gonna get to that when he gets
a number we haven't done numbers yet
have we
uh we haven't done numbers with you guys
yet
oh that's why I call us don't worry
we'll get to that
yeah yeah don't worry we're going to get
to that inshallah I won't introduce it
yet
yeah numbers is coming
no it comes it comes there's rulings all
right
next one uh
uh
so if he's got two sisters you say Nam
Li okay
okay I have two sisters
okay
yeah
so you don't use and so say for example
because we haven't got to this lesson
yet
this lesson hasn't come yet as far as
I'm concerned but if he had two sisters
we say
[Music]
yeah all right
uh
you see that's how he said if you say
you don't have a car you say la martinis
it
might indeed see La first then Martini
okay
so bicycle
[Music]
um
no I don't have
so I don't have a bike well done
well done now I'm in the column well
done
oh now I'm in the Oklahoma Adida
in the aklam cathedral
in the accla Montana we have various
pens multiple series I have a lot
Surplus amounts you know in the Oklahoma
Hadid I have numerous
pens
Nam
Ed
so notebook
foreign
uh you would say sorry
yeah but that's another lesson that's
coming
so for the sake of the conversation you
would say no who are tired
he's a big Merchant
I mean
now we're returning back to the
Hayward
conversation
where's Muhammad from
in Hindi sir
[Music]
Hindi says
Muhammad is from Hind
well done
let's finish this up
what's his language
well done
it's all
right
he says my languages
Urdu
yeah Muhammad says my language is Urdu
hu where's his father
the conversation it says
is that correct
Phil Kuwait
his father is in Kuwait
SA
where's his mother
um who
Kuwait
his mother is also in Kuwait
U where's Hamza from
Milan
yeah bunny so
you sure
trying to find Hamza here
no I mean Aina Hamza where's Hamza from
ah he goes on to say
so his language is
Japanese I would assume he's Japanese
foreign I assume he is Japanese
[Music]
well done
uh
where's his father
who
[Music]
um
okay
[Music]
here
he's a famous doctor
uh
where's zainab where is zainab not where
is zainab from where is zainab
inazainable
Iraqi
zaynabu is in Iraq
where is her husband
her husband's also in
Iraq
is a husband a teacher no he's an
engineer
I'm not sure what's that architect I
can't remember I think it's something
like that I can't remember exactly
uh uh play it will end it there how long
was that uh
for a families
next week we'll finish up with
everything else it's only four pages
cool